gilles verdez alors j'ai travaillé alors
vas-y c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
c'est qu'ils réprouvent et cki retrouvé
mireille mathieu et julien pierre
les salaires parce que je crois que tu
es mireille mathieu qui nous regardent
toujours allez c'est bon catastrophique
2 0 valérie benaïm la 3c papeete papier
merci alors ses volets qui va les
trouver
c'est rené qui vaille c'est trouver à
chaque fois attention laurence sailly
évasée mathieu alors les chenilles je
vais essayer de vous faire tourner je me
suis pas sûr mais tu sais que je t'aime
bien mais là franchement trouver quoi
bastien continue je vais voir si des
gens trouvés chez deux allez-y dites
nous si vous aussi vous trouvez continue
alors ce que j'ai à vous dire ça très
bien voilà apparemment c'est moi qui
venais c'était moi et moi tu as compris
voit benjamin castaldi va dit bonsoir
petit chat médiateur fenêtre gaulle à la
fortune les ailiers samuel robail pas à
yves montand mais tape il tape à
quelqu'un de plus face à une grosse
faute au grand-père contemporain
bonjour savages je suis content d'être
là parce que la télévision qu'on fait
des ces différents la télé confiné on
est chez soi devant l'ordinateur à la
micro et on peut s'exprimer
aucunement oui j'ai tâté les corvidés et
j'aime aussi le rappel johnny afin de
trouver ces thèmes et c'est pas mal pas
mamie
jean michel daire voisine voilà on ne
peut dire ce ton devant q l'ailé qui se
permet de critiquer le professeur raoul
de l'ol sont des gens extrêmement calme
toi c'est bon merde cicero heitz a
d'ailleurs vite ribeiro des maldives à
regarder il ya un garçon qui a beaucoup
plus de talent c'est jessy mutation
vraiment sur youtube il fait des trucs
exceptionnel il imite à la perfection
quasiment tous les personnages des
simpson il prend la voix de 50
personnages de la série
je vous l'avais montré une première fois
il fait des trucs de ouf regardez sa
vidéo fait un carton je voulais
absolument vous montrer ça c'est du très
lourd regarde si vous pensez que les
imitateurs c'est ringard et que la
nouvelle génération sur you tube tik tok
et snap chat n'est pas client de cet
humour vous vous trompez une nouvelle
génération d'imitateur 2.0 a débarqué
sur internet
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que certains ont du talent c'est le cas
par exemple du conte jesse mutation qui
durant le confinement s'est lancé le
défi d'imiter 50 personnages du dessin
animé les simpson en trois minutes le
tout dans un sketch où il fait parler du
coronavirus aux habitants de springfield
on y retrouve bien sûr au maire cpc
match et perrine et bouffées de l'oeuf
rigueur safa marge maire y en a
peut-être dans le placard l'épicier à
poux bon show motion shot mais aussi le
pote de bart le fameux mille house et
moi normalement m'avait dit que ça
resterait pas longtemps une vidéo déjà
visionnée des centaines de milliers de
fois sur les réseaux et que quand on
s'accroche pour toucher les jeunes
il va peut-être falloir penser à
travailler d'autres voies que celle de
raffarin et de valéry giscard d'estaing
[Musique]
il ya quelqu'un qui dit bien laurence
sailly où elle a abusé du sur le jus de
carotte où elle est confinée avec
bernard montiel yake les gens qui disent
tout j'avais très bonne mine
lg civilisation extrêmement fort et
m'ont rappelé je vous avais montré une
une vidéo où il faisait plein de voix
avec la chanson ne revient pas non ne
revient pas de réduire graduellement
foire et regardez où je la revois il est
énorme mais surtout de fond de la boîte
ne m'appartient pas si je veux je
l'achète
faut qu'ils comprennent si tu veux pas
d'importance
oui c'est nous les grosses moules à iyad
allawi jacques brel qu'une bêtise elle
lancé sous étudier cet état il va
peut-être l'etei ya du chic et 2000 elle
ne revient prêt exceptionnel des
imitations voilà raifort fort très fort
oui raymond relais taille limitation pas
moins les manu m'a fait moi ok vas-y
vas-y bagnole avec la baisse des
salaires à chuter le dollar a dit
regardez l fallait traiter spectateurs
ils vont kiffer la tête
vas-y wade c'est quoi le truc a dit
c'est quoi va dire au fello nous refait
le nouveau-né tindouf et qui fait avec
la mère du poupon se rendent dans les
alpes a dissous qui rigole on n'a pas
besoin de nous rembourser le doliprane
aujourd'hui c'est trop fort trop fort
heureusement c'est pas du tout ça
rigolait bravo est franchement très bon
oui mais jamais vous sert il ya un petit
truc quand même une petite imitation
fait au plaisir allez c'est vous dire
qu'elle imitation je vous faire après le
confinement
je vous le dire comme je le pensais que
français il ya bien un secteur qui
connaît pas la crise avec le confinement
je vous dire c'est lequel eh ben je
voulais dire c'est celui des sites et
des applications de rencontre pourquoi
je vous le dire moi j'ai pas connu car
l'assurance-vie j'aurais très bien pu
merci il a maigri le temps réel